and i think in order to to make a break
uh breakout format you really need to be
extremely original and sort of break the
barriers
of a lot of things that have been done
before
[Music]
assaf gill thank you for joining me on
my show how are you
i'm not too bad thanks very much
you know i'm not used to seeing your
face i'm used to seeing
the title of your company at the end of
pretty much every show that i enjoy
watching on tv
so it's definitely an interesting
experience now watching you in person
uh but but gil assaf sorry gil obviously
the last name but
what's really i think fascinating to me
is that
you really are a key figure in the
entertainment industry in israel and
and i think that's what i'm especially
curious to hear about in these next 20
minutes is some of the thought process
that goes behind
creating entertainment bringing that to
reality and really productizing it
for the market here in israel so assaf
please
take take it away and tell me a little
bit about your journey and how do you
even get started with even
wanting to be on television if i'm
correct ahuta ladeem was one of the
first appearances
yes well i i actually start i wasn't
born a producer i started out as an
actor i trained in london uh
for four years and then uh when coming
back to israel i i acted
uh in theater and a bit of television
here
uh after which i sort of
decided that it wasn't it for me
which i'm i'm really happy about that
decision because
unlike uh other
would-be actors or people who wanted
wanted it but never achieved it i'm
really i was really through
with my wish to be an actor so i'm
um once that happened to me i was really
dedicated to
uh producing um
and i i think
one of one of the key issues in my
career at least was the fact that
the success or as you mentioned the fact
that i'm
almost everywhere on television in
israel as a producer
didn't come to me very quick quickly uh
i think that for about 15 years i was
producing sort of small shows
uh getting uh you know
learning quite a lot through uh the
process of
working uh and only
uh at the tender age of 43 i think
i really uh hit the prime time
in commercial television in israel which
uh
really was a big breakthrough for me and
from the word goal
right since i uh i was on prime time
i was very fortunate to have
a huge success in almost every
show i produced assaf i have to pick
your brain about the soul industry
because
you know coming from the from the tech
scene you know i think the equivalent to
you saying reaching prime time is
sort of reaching like an exit uh for
startups right or going public that's
sort of like
i guess the analogy but but talk to me a
little bit about how this
industry is built and what are some of
the biggest challenges
that it takes for a producer to reach at
the tender age of 43
to reach that prime time experience
well um you know television in israel is
uh
is a small marketplace and it's
extremely competitive
because there's uh um
a large number of um
production companies uh with a limited
amount of
networks so that makes it very tough
uh actually throughout the years
um i don't think it uh it became any
easier it only um it feels like
uh sort of a a big uh war
uh going through the years um
and first and foremost i must say that
uh
the battle is for uh great shows great
ideas
uh formats uh if there are sort of
purchase for israel ip that is purchased
uh
to be produced locally from successful
shows uh elsewhere
and also here and there when we do have
the chance to
uh create our own uh original shows in
ip
right that makes a lot of sense and talk
to me a little bit about what what is
the format so
i'm guessing that it's some structure to
a show that might repeat itself might be
able to then scale also to other places
but
talk to me a little bit because you have
both the guild production side and guild
formats right
which are which are they're like
siblings entities
but talk to me about each one separately
and how they work together
here in the israeli marketplace sure
so um basically the formats i'm talking
about or the formats that we're dealing
with
um non-scripted formats so we're not
talking about scripted shows we're
talking about non-scripted television
uh and the format is basically a very uh
comprehensive concept uh
which is very well defined
and uh you know impossible to uh
imitate if you like without going into
lawsuits
um and it's
always starting out as an idea and then
being developed further and further
sometimes
uh through pilot episodes sometimes it's
being commissioned
uh and gil productions is really a pure
production entity
that uh you know currently in in the
israeli
uh marketplace we're producing uh six
really huge shows uh for
um all networks here uh
and and guild formats was established as
a company
in uh
2015 because we came to realize that we
have a lot of our
or our own original stuff that we would
like to distribute and
cell outside of israel and we made some
very nice successes
uh through this ib this original iep
some of it uh was produced
initially in israel and then exported
and some was actually first
uh produced first outside of israel
uh so that was uh even more exciting
so i mean let's say that i'm i'm you
know a young a
young media entrepreneur and i have an
idea for a show that
is called come eat with me by the way i
love that show um
and i want to put it on i i
i have come down with me i i i want to
comment
i want to actually start this up as as
as you know
a real proper show what are some of the
big milestones that i'll have to go
through as a media
entrepreneur or is coming in with this
format whether i pitch it to guild
formats or somebody else
what are some of the steps that i'll
have to go through
i think that you know unlike uh perhaps
tech
[Music]
ideas that might be
uh sometimes easier to launch
i find because i'm getting pitched uh
on an average of two format like this
per day
so uh it's it's uh hundreds per year
and i must say that uh most of them
uh are not that good
because you're like a venture capital
investor in
in a way i am yes um
i i think that some of the ideas are
very
um you know they are very much similar
to other things that are on
air with slight differences that don't
really make
that much of a difference and i think in
order to
to make a break uh breakout format
you really need to be extremely original
and sort of break the barriers
of a lot of things that have been done
before
um on the other hand i think that
some of the ideas i'm being pitched with
are
okay great actually on paper but once
you
uh go into the nitty-gritty of producing
them of making them
a television show most people don't
really understand the barriers of
television or how
a television show is produced
and that's why some of the ideas are
purely hypothetical because they cannot
get to a practical
um you know they cannot really be
achieved
so uh it's a really tough process but if
you do
have uh an original successful format
you can you know it can it can
potentially
bring you lots of money and lots of um
you know could be a big springboard if
if you do
manage to create something original and
that could be
successful right talk to me a little bit
about reality television
that's also a big part of what you do
what why
do i love reality tv so much why do i
find myself
able to sit through watching an entire
season of a reality show without
stopping
while i'm not i think that's maybe the
only thing i can do without stopping for
hours
why is that i think that uh
you know what what what always works on
television
is is a story and it's always a personal
story
and there's always uh need there's
always
that there there's a need for uh
some sort of stake of what the people
are going through
there's a challenge there's something
out of the ordinary
uh some of the reality shows that we all
know
uh when wanting to achieve the
uh you know this challenge
for instance in survivor they could send
people to
a remote island staff them and and
and put them through impossible
challenges just to get the personal
story the personal truth
some other shows uh which have been also
fortunate to produce
uh are there the challenges there
um naturally for instance one of the
um successful show i produced a few
years ago
in in israel was called baby boom uh
in the original uk version it's uh
it's called one born every minute and
what we did there was just
document births in in a in a hospital
world
uh and it was extremely
emotional and dramatic
simply just by putting a camera there
because you know the challenge was there
we didn't need to create it so some some
reality shows
have to manipulate and create the
uh the challenge and the drama whereas
some other
other shows uh uh the drama is sort of
in
inherent in in the process i prefer the
other
type of shows because i think that uh
nowadays uh viewers are very
uh critical uh they they have they
they can see the manipulations uh and
and i think that
as long as the person involved the
person on on television is
going through something real uh it's
it's
it's better and i think most of my shows
were focused on that
i think that's that's fascinating and i
i have to say i agree i enjoy watching
both
the very early season of these seasons
of these shows but i also enjoy watching
the
later seasons of these shows and the new
reality shows like baby boom
which which i also love and and you can
tell the difference you can tell the
difference in authenticity and you can
tell when that person is going through
an emotional
experience that that is very relevant
that you can actually connect with
but assaf tell me a little bit about the
about the trajectory of where we're
headed with with television and reality
tv
also so what have been some of the major
changes aside from the authenticity in
the past
you know decade or so and where are we
headed towards in the future
well you know everyone is talking about
uh
the problem of
linear television and is it going to
still be relevant
uh i think it is because i think
uh the challenge of current uh day
television is
uh television really needs to reinvent
itself
as a must-see uh platform uh
you can watch netflix uh you can
binge shows and obviously have lots of
fun with it but i think the challenge of
linear television
is to be able to uh offer
viewers something that they really need
to see they
won't be able to see on uh the svod
platforms and uh
i think i i i do see a long future
of television ahead of us uh you know my
recent show in israel which is
you know a huge success uh everywhere
the mass singer
um is is something like that because
it is something that has a great deal of
engagement
with viewers uh people need to be
involved they want to be involved it's
it's it's um
you know it's the talk the next day
everywhere
and it's the type of show which um
you know brings back the value of
television
and i think that's part of the things i
like to do because
i do like to produce things
which are a bit of an adventure a bit
of something refreshing something
different
and uh and i think that was
one of the reasons why i i
you know uh took an option on this
format
very early before it launched in the u.s
and some other forms as well
when i felt that there is something that
is
is is different there is an adventure
in having this on television and i think
that's i love it
not doing more of the same doing things
which are
completely different
and stuff i think that's just incredible
tell me a little bit about yourself why
are you so excited about starting new
shows and continuing to innovate
and you mentioned that you started off
really getting into the bits and pieces
and
the exciting parts of it at 43 but why
today why do you still enjoy getting
pitched
at least two ideas per day and then
continuing to do new formats
uh you know i love what i do uh
it's really not something that uh
uh when i wake up in the morning i i
don't have any
qualms about what i'm doing i don't
uh have other dreams it's not like i
wish
i would have you know i would do
something else
it never never happened to me i really
am totally enchanted with what i'm doing
and uh i love to create
and and i think part of the
magic of creating for television is
being able
to uh to use a lot of your
senses and both intellect and and
and emotions but i would say first and
foremost intuition
i think television for me at least
television works a lot
on on intuition and uh
and that's what why i love this
field because you are going through
a lot of unknowns you're going through a
lot of black holes
uh you're not sure what's going to
happen when you
you know how you're going to come out uh
of the other side
and that's part of the magic of
television and that's why it's so
exciting
and it always has been what's been the
greatest
what's been the greatest challenge that
that you had to overcome
in the in doing the amazing work that
you're doing right now
well the biggest challenges uh
uh uh me pitching to other people
of course so you're talking about uh
um as if i'm um
vc being pitched to but i'm also
pitching to networks in israel i'm
pitching to networks abroad
to production companies abroad uh
that's always a big challenge uh
because normally you're in a position
when uh you when you're pitching
to people who are very
anxious about making bold moves and
and and taking risks and
if you are being adventurous uh which is
what i like to to do uh it's always
uh it's always a challenge
pitching to people who are almost prone
to taking risks risk-averse people
and that's uh
i love that and if you look over and you
know the incredible
career that you've had and i have to
first of all i have to say thank you
because i think that
you know besides from from from being an
innovator and creating all these things
you really
you impacted so many lives and and you
know i i can still recall to this and i
will never forget you know those
saturday nights when i would sit with my
family everybody together
huddle in front of the screen because
we're excited about some somebody's
journey
whether it's through baby boom or
another reality tv i think it brings
people together i think it creates
excitement and creates
an internal excitement for every person
watching it and i think
that allowing us to experience these
emotions
is a gift and so i want to thank you for
for giving us that gift
and also thank you for being so generous
with your time and coming here
asap before we leave i have to ask you
the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
well i'll pick up on a lot of things i
said here i would
probably say um it's a bit embarrassing
but uh i'll probably say that
i'm intuitive i'm i'm uh experienced
because i took me some time before i
made
uh a move and went successful
and i'm adventurous these are the three
things i love
i love it thank you so so much this is
really really wonderful
and thank you very much stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you thank you very much michael
thank you